[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في مجلس من قناه الجزيره قالت
مصادر في الجيش السوداني للجزيره ان قوه
من الدعم السريع اغتالت والي غرب دارفور
خميس ابكر بعد اختطافه عصره الاربعاء من
مدينه الجنينه الى جهه مجهوله وتداول
ناشطون صورا للقبض على الوالي خميس ابكر
ثم نشرت لاحقا صور وهو مقتول وقد دانا
رئيس مجلس السياده بالسودان عبد الفتاح
البرهان مقتل الوالي واتهم الدعم السريع
بالمسؤوليه وجاءتها قالت مصادر في الدعم
السريع انها تدين حادث القتل الذي قالت
انه جاء في اطار الصراع القبلي واتهمت
الجيش بالمسؤوليه لانه يصلح احد طرفي
النزاع القبلي على حد قولها هذا وافاد
مصدرا طبي بوقوع عدد من القتلى والجرحى
جراء قصف استهدف منطقه حي النهضه امس
بضحيه الانقاذ جنوبيه الخرطوم وفي ام
درمان شرق الخرطوم
قال فيليبو جراندي مفوض الامم المتحده
السامي لشؤون اللاجئين اذا الاشتباكات
العنيفه في مخيمات النازحين في شمال
دارفور اسفرت عن مقتل اكثر من 100 شخص
واضف جراند في تغريده ان هناك تقارير وصفه
بالمروعه عن العنف في الجنسي ضد النساء
والفتيات
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهادا
شابا فلسطينيا برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال اقتحامها مدينه نابلس
بالضفه الغربيه وفجرت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منزل عائله الاسير اسامه
الطويل في حي المخفيه في مدينه نابلس
والمتهم بالمشاركه في قتل جندي اسرائيلي
في شهر تشرين اول اكتوبر الماضي
قالت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه انها نشرت
طائرات من طراز 22
في الشرق الاوسط في ضوء السلوك غير الامن
للطائرات الروسيه واضافت القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه ان انتهاك القوات الجويه
الروسيه اجواء
منع النزاع يزيد مخاطر التصعيد وسوء
التقدير
اعلنت السلطات الروسيه في القرم اسقاط 9
مسيرات اوكرانيه فوق شبه الجزيره فقالت
السلطات الروسيه انه تم تدمير ثلاث منها
عبر معدات الكترونيه بينما اسقطت البقيه
بواسطه قوات الدفاع الجوي واشارت الى ان
احدى الطائرات مسيره منفجرت في قريه دوكو
تشايفو دون ان تتسبب في ايقاع ضحايا
قالت الاداره العسكريه في اوديسا ان
الدفاعات الجويه تتعامل مع هجوم جوي
يستهدفه المدينه وذكرت قياده عمليات جنوب
اوكرانيا ان القوات الروسيه تهاجم جنوبيه
اوكرانيا بمسيارات مفخخه وان هناك تهديدا
بوجود هجوم صاروخي فقال رئيس الاداره
العسكريه في انفجارات تدور في مدينه
كريفيري جنوب شرقيه اوكرانيا
انتهى هذا الموجز
[موسيقى]